le corps des bébés et plein de mystères
saviez vous par exemple qu'ils étaient
capables de régénérer leurs doigts s'ils
étaient coupées ou qu'ils avaient une
force exceptionnelle comparé à leur
poids on a fait ça gré pdb à des bâtons
et ils ont tenu plusieurs minutes pas
sûr que vous puissiez en faire autant en
fait l'anatomie des bébés très
différente de la nôtre ce qui m'intrigue
comment réagir et leurs corps s'il était
mis dans des conditions extrêmes et si
pour tester ça on les emmenait dans les
parcs d'attraction les plus extrêmes du
monde et vous comprendrez pourquoi ils
sont interdits aux enfants certains ont
déjà tenté l'expérience
mettre un bébé dans le missionne space
de disney ça fait quoi dans les années
40 un étrange manège fait son apparition
dans le festival de la bière en
allemagne ça tourne vite ça vous plaque
au mur et ça donnerait presque envie de
vomir le rotor est née 3 g
d'accélération
situe pèse 80 kg tu en feras 240 sous
l'effet centrifuge ton corps c'est la
panique ton sang descend vers le bas et
ta fréquence cardiaque augmente pour
essayer de pousser un maximum de sang au
cerveau située reste trop longtemps un
peu moins d'une heure le choeur
n'arrivera pas à suivre ta vision va se
réduire et tu vas perdre connaissance
6,3 g d'accélération de font peur dit
'ok pour devenir astronaute sur la
mission apollo 11 il fallait passer par
la diabolique une version hardcore de
l'attraction qui monte à 15 j'ai regardé
la tête qu'ils font on est d'accord que
vous avez pas envie d'y être et bien
pourtant disney a voulu imiter sa en
ouvrant michonne space en 2004
l'attraction est tellement horrible
qu'elle est équipée de sacs à vomi et de
panneaux kit des conseils des montées
elle a été fermée en 2006 après avoir
causé de décès avant de réouvrir alors
comment réagir et un bébé là dedans eh
bien figurez vous que des gens ont testé
en 1965 15 chercheurs a proposé une
manière originale de faire accoucher les
femmes par force centrifuge la table
d'accouchement devait tourner très vite
80 tours par minute c'est plus que le
manège le bébé était ainsi terrine
naturellement vers l'extérieur un fils
et leur tenait à la sortie pour éviter
qu'ils s'envolent la machine a été
breveté mais bizarrement personne n'a
jamais voulu l'attenté le chercheur a
quand même reçu un nid du nobel un prix
satiriques qui vise à récompenser les
inventions atypique mais qui porte à
réflexion vous rigolez mais c'est pas
totalement une mauvaise idée sur le
papier un bébé résisterez très bien une
attraction comme mission space et ce
grâce à leur anatomie déjà pour éviter
de perdre de la chaleur et de la
croissance la fréquence cardiaque d'un
bébé est très élevée on parle de 160
battements par minute au repos presque
deux fois plus qu'un adulte parfait
pourtant qu'est l'évanouissement
deuxième avantage leur diaphragme ceara
créé le mouvement de respiration bien
chez eux c'est plus grand avec des
poumons plus élastique dans le manège ta
respiration d'adultes va devenir
chaotique accélérant t risque
d'évanouissement le bébé lui serait
théoriquement plus à l'aise dernier
avantage et pas des moindres un bébé
pèse considérablement moins lourd qu'un
adulte environ trois kilos ça veut dire
que la force du rotor aurait un très
faible impact sur lui la distance entre
la tête et les pieds étant aussi réduite
plus facile de compenser pour le coeur
voilà tout ça c'est beau mais les bébés
ont quand même un gros problème leur
ossature ils ont 136 au de plus qu'un
adulte où pourrait se dire que ça leur
donne une armure supplémentaires mais
n'ont cédé aux claques et oumou quelque
chose plus proche du cartilage qui
fusionne en grandissant pour donner des
eaux définitif si vous regardez
attentivement leur crâne ça bouge au
rythme de la respiration les médecins
décrivent leur cerveau comme une
gélatine non fixée et c'est logique
c'est pour faciliter la sortie de lors
de l'accouchement leur crâne est en fait
un puzzle de fontanel des parties molles
qui vont se souder avec le temps il
faudra quand même attendre deux ans
avant que bébé la tête dior te fais la
vitesse de l'attraction serait fatale
agité un crâne en développement détruire
et ses cellules cérébrales et écraserait
même le peu d'eau solide qu'il possède
déjà des chercheurs de l'université
d'oslo ont fait une étude sur une poupée
ultra perfectionné à dix neuf mille
dollars
résultat une secousse violente sur un
bébé reviendrait à lui donner une force
de 10 g dans le corps plus qu'un pilote
d'avion de chasse en 1959 77 % des
accidents de voiture impliquant un
enfant
relatifs à son crâne c'est presque 10%
supérieur aux adultes mettre un bébé
dans le kingda ka ça fait quoi cent
soixante dix mètres de haut 206 km heure
en moins de 4 secondes et une boucle de
270 degrés sec ça c'est king t'as qu'à
la montagne russe la plus haute du monde
on pourrait penser que c'est sécurisé
mais non en 2019 on reporte presque 500
cas d'accident relatifs aux montagnes
russes aux états unis c'est presque 40
accidents par mois le premier problème
c'est bien sûr les vomissements suffit
de voir la tête que font mcfly karito
après leur record de trente et un tour
de montagnes russes ça c'est parce que
l'attraction modifient constamment ta
vitesse est à direction tu es perdu dans
un conflit sensorielle quand tu as le
mal de mer ton corps et l'eau on
dévouement contradictoires ça tenait
dans le mal est ici c'est un peu pareil
en réalité les sensations sont surtout
visuel et park font exprès de faire
frôler des murs constamment pour te
rappeler que tu vas vite essaye de
fermer les yeux dans le manège ça sera
complètement différent c'est pareil que
quand tu es malade en voiture si tu
regardes ton téléphone pendant un virage
les yeux vont donner une information
contradictoire avec ton oreille interne
qui s'occupe de ton équilibre du coup tu
synchronise pas ton oreille avec ce que
tu vois et ça te rend malade le deuxième
problème c'est évidemment que tu te
prends l'accélération en pleine phase 4
g au total dans ton corps tu passe de 0
à 2 106 km heure plusieurs fois dans le
manège ce qui a des effets dramatiques
sur son organisme car tout n'accélère
pas de façon homogène en parlant de ça
en artiste a imaginé le manège de
l'euthanasie une montagne russe qui a
pour but de tuer ses passagers dans
l'élégance et l'euphorie c'est pas moi
qui le dit hein c'est son concepteur tu
montes à 560 mètres de hauteur puis tu
chutes à 300 km heure tu passes dans
cette boucle de plus en plus petites qui
maintiennent ton corps à 10g les taux en
permanence dans la vraie vie les
accidents les plus fréquents sont des
ruptures de vaisseaux sanguins et des
hémorragies cérébrales en 2011 une femme
de 47 ans est décédé à l'hôpital à cause
des dégâts de la force du manège dans
son cerveau autant vous dire qu'un bébé
n'aurait aucune chance les secousses
constante et la vitesse pourraient au
mieux traumatisée au pire le tuer c'est
pour ça que pour monter dans le king
dacca tu dois avoir au moins huit ans et
faire un maître 37 et attention à ne pas
en abuser cette histoire d'un garçon de
12 ans qui a passé neuf heures à faire
des montagnes russes le lendemain il par
l'hôpital avec des maux de tête des
troubles de l'élocution un côté du
visage a fait c est une jambe droite
qu'il ne pouvait plus bouger la veille
déjà ça n'allait pas très bien les
parents l'ont retrouvé dans la piscine à
vagues du parc en train de se noyer le
corps à moitié paralysée des tests ont
relevé qu'il avait subi un avc
il faudra 24 heures d'opération pour
pouvoir soigner l'enfant est le remettre
sur pied mettre un bébé dans l'orlando
frivole ça fait quoi l'orlando frivole
et la plus haute tour de chute du monde
130 mètres de haut le 24 mars 2022 le
manège fait face à une catastrophe un
garçon de 11 ans est tombé et malgré une
intervention rapide il n'aura pas
survécu à ses blessures et ça à cause de
sa ceinture de sécurité mal attachés qui
aura cédé une fois en haut l'attraction
se décompose en trois phases une montée
pendant laquelle lentement sur regrette
d'avoir jeté ton billet une phase
stationnaire en haut où tu peux
apprécier la vue puis finalement la
chute où tu vois ta vie défiler si oncle
est certes elle seule à cette vitesse tu
finirais en crêpe heureusement le
mécanisme est bien fait et des aimants
géante fresnes avant ouais des aimants
malheureusement en 2017 en turquie ce
dispositif n'était pas correctement
installé la nacelle s'est écrasé sans
freiner faisant 17 blessés graves
cependant une chute libre quelque chose
des tronches pas sans toi pense que tu
vas mourir tu as peur mais tu es aussi
euphorique respiration accrue audition
modifié vision qui s'obstrue voulu
s'engage à augmenter pupilles dilatées
papillons dans l'estomac votre corps se
met en mode survie maximale vous libère
en fait un max d'adrénaline et de
noradrénaline des hormones du stress qui
se déclenche lorsque ton corps a besoin
de réagir à son plein potentiel pendant
un court instant sauf que là vous savez
que vous ne risquez rien et vous pouvez
donc profiter de l'euphorie c'est pour
ça que certains passent de lapereaux
rire en moins de quelques instants si un
adulte c'est réguler ces hormones
naturellement et la conscience du faible
danger de l'attraction abb lui n'en est
pas capable déjà qu'ils déclenchent du
stress pour des choses comme la fin ou
la fatigue imaginez le placer dans ce
manège sans comprendre ce qui va se
passer son organisme va aller puiser
bien trop rapidement et potentiellement
générer des maladies graves pour son
coeur ses défenses immunitaires
des études ont démontré qu'un stress
intense sur les enfants étaient la cause
de maladies chroniques comme le diabète
plus surprenant encore le stress toxique
peut même activer ou désactiver certains
gènes de votre adn ça pourrait être une
cause de schizophrénie ou l'autisme
comme on l'a remarqué chez les souris
après si on regarde d'un point de vue
purement physique un bébé serait à même
de résister alors leur dos free fall
c'est surprenant je sais mais laissez
moi vous expliquer un bébé est plus
petit et plus léger
quand il tombe il n'a qu'un quart de la
vitesse terminale d'un adulte du coup
certains peuvent survivre à des chutes
impressionnantes aux états unis en 2014
un bébé de 15 mois est tombé du balcon
au 11e étage de son immeuble et il a
survécu en 2011 c'est plus de deux
millions d'enfants en dessous de 14 ans
qui sont amies pour des chutes aux états
unis parmi eux seulement une centaine
décède à proportion égale chez les
adultes c'est 20 % de décès en plus
mettre un bébé dans le canal beau loupé
ça fait quoi en 1996 l'accès au parc au
new-jersey ferme ses portes après six
décès la cause une attraction en
particulier le canon ball loupé un
toboggan au tout ce qu'il ya de plus
banal
à part que les constructeurs ont eu la
bonne idée de placer un looping ça
faisait si peur aux employés qu'ils ont
été payées 100 $ pour le tester et une
fois ouvert c'était un carnage les nez
cassé s'enchaîner à chaque sortie on a
même retrouvé des dents logé dans la
boucle alors qu'est ce que ça donnerait
si on y mettait un bébé l'eau n'est pas
un problème ce sont de très bons nageurs
les bébés ont la capacité primitive de
savoir nager si vous les mettez au fond
de l'eau ils ne retiendront pas réflexe
leur respiration je sais que ces images
peuvent choquer mais elles sont sans
danger un bébé c'est faire de l'apnée en
2018 on ne recensait que 64 cas de
noyades chez l'enfant contre 400 chez
l'adulte en france non le problème d'un
bébé dans le canal bonne loupe est tout
autre la secousse du looping elle est
tellement forte et violente qu'elle
causerait des dommages mortels vous avez
peut-être déjà vu à la télévision des
spots de prévention contre le syndrome
du bébé secoué genre le bébé pleure
s'énerve les parents il le secoue un peu
et crack tu peut briser des parties de
la nuque en faisant ça tu agis de son
cerveau dans tous les sens et comme il
n'est pas encore terminé tu va détruire
des cellules cérébrales le bébé entre
les scènes des yeux tu du couple arrivé
d'oxygène dans le pire des cas tu peux
même fracturé son crâne d'autres zones
comme ses cotes en 2009 en france
c'était plus de 1000 cas recensés de
bébé touché par ce mal serre c'est
colossal en fait autant vous dire que le
looping dan parks est il bien pire que
ça les mannequins d'essai pour
l'attraction aurait été démembré voire
même décapité durant les tests on se
demande comment une telle horreur a pu
ouvrir ses portes comme pour les trois
attractions vu précédemment le risque
n'est pas seulement physique mais aussi
psychologique les traumatise centre
beaucoup plus facilement lors de la
petite enfance et on risquerait de
détruire des vies par la peur des
hauteurs de la vitesse de l'eau ou de la
chute heureusement aujourd'hui il existe
de plus en plus de parcs souvent des
attractions adaptés aux tout petits
l'écart au ciel sont les exemples les
plus connus plus d'être divertissant il
permet à bébé d'apprendre donc oui vous
pouvez emmener vos bébés dans les parcs
d'attractions peut-être te souviens-tu
de quand tu étais petit
sourire de ta maman qui te fait un geste
demain à chaque tour de manège ça sera
peut-être à toi de faire ce geste demain
[Musique]